la situation en guadeloupe on en parle
avec philippe bélair secrétaire général
de la cgt santé guadeloupe
philippe bélair bonjour peut-être
première question pour faire écho aux
témoignages de cette infirmière que l'on
vient d'écouter
manifestement la situation en guadeloupe
et très quantité oui bonjour plus que
compliquée en fait la gestion a été
quasiment la même avec une semaine de
retard sur le plan national
effectivement les autorités politiques
et sanitaires ne pas lui donner ou non
parle de voulu voir venir la situation
est plus que critique d'autant plus que
nous sommes une île
la configuration est eu l'air de la
guadeloupe est encore aggravé la
situation dans la mesure où ce rappel et
nous avons toujours dit depuis quelques
années que nous sommes dans notre ville
il ya énormément de risques géologiques
volcaniques
c'est sans compter les autres risques
épidémiques comme la belgique
mesic à nous sommes donc dans une
situation à je ne parle même pas de
l'incendié fut il ya dix ans le 3 ans
nous sommes véritablement de 4,85 et et
d'ailleurs nous avons été opérés les
autorités politiques d'un immense
il faut rester sans réponse et nous
voyons que les choses se font je ne
dirais pas en catimini mais de manière
très confidentielle et 15 autoritaires
comme pour rattraper des erreurs
alors que nous mêmes nous avions toutes
les organisations syndicales confondues
d'ailleurs nous avions interpellé les
autorités sur la situation risquait de
s'aggraver en cas de situations
compliquées comme c'est le cas au début
avec le soyouz monsieur bel air ce que
vous dites c'est que le système de santé
ou à la loupe est défaillant en tout cas
plus que sur l'hexagone et bien avant
l'avancée de l'épidémie
oui encore plus bien que les taux
affichent se targue d'être prêt nous en
tout cas nous prenons nos
responsabilités nous préférons demander
où se prémunir de faire en sorte que
justement ce virus ne circule pas
lorsque celle ci ce sont les individus
qui font circuler le virus mais
malheureusement nous sommes obligés sans
kolnik au film nous sommes obligés de
constater que la gestion était
catastrophique donc dans quinze jours ou
trois semaines vers falloir faire un
bilan
le bilan terrible il va falloir que les
responsables ce soit autour d'une table
côte d'ivoire sur ce monsieur m'a l'air
très rapidement comment se passe le
confinement en guadeloupe à ce que la
mesure est respecté mais a eu du mal à
réguler mais de plus en plus précis dans
l'allier ont observé que quand même
[Musique]
les janvier en fait manquons puits après
les injections étaient contradictoires
je n'arrivais pas à savoir 10 de gens de
ne pas sortir et d'aller voter
c'est contradictoire là maintenant les
choses deviennent plus clairs les gens y
compris les gens sont nos comportements
depuis six mois il est en plus qu'ils
ont parfaitement saisi la dangerosité de
ce 10 mai philippe bélair merci d'avoir
été en direct avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général de la cgtg
santé guadeloupe merci